-Our next guest is an Emmy and
Tony Award-winning actor
you know from shows such as "The
Practice," "Boston Legal,"
"The Librarians" and
"The John Larroquette Show."
He returns as Dan Fielding in
the revival of "Night Court,"
which premieres with
back-to-back episodes
on January 17th here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Alright, look. I just want to
say this one thing.
I'm only here to help out
temporarily, a few days.
-I'm hearing weeks.
-If you keep smiling like that,
I'm out of here right now,
so just knock it off.
That's better.
-"Better, Your Honor."
-[ Chuckles ]
I'm already regretting this.
-Please welcome to the show
the one, the only
John Larroquette, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
How are you?
-I'm still alive.
-You're still alive.
We're proving it.
We're proving it on live TV.
It's so exciting.
-Oh, this is so great.
I've not been in front of a live
audience in quite a while.
-It's really nice, isn't it?
-It's invigorating.
It's really good to hear.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It makes a huge difference.
This is very exciting for me.
This is a show that I remember
being a huge fan of back
in the day.
It ran for nine seasons.
These are sort of things that
don't happen anymore.
I think everybody knew it.
It was nominated for
over 30 Emmys.
Is it a trip to return to it
30 years later?
-Oh, an absolute trip, yes.
I mean, it was a trip that
I reluctantly, finally decided
to join after a lot of cajoling,
from Melissa Rauch particularly.
-Who is the lovely judge
in that scene. Yeah. Yeah.
-She is a lovely judge.
And because of the way it was
presented to me, you know,
as an actor, I became aware
that, "Oh, wait,
hold on a second.
How often does one get a chance
to look at a character that you
played 30 years ago
and see him now
30 years in the future?
What's happened to him?"
As an actor, it seemed like
an interesting problem
to actually solve a little bit.
-And it has.
There is a huge change, right?
Like, Dan Fielding was
arrogance incarnate.
Like, that was my memory of him,
a prosecutor.
And now you've obviously been
changed by life.
Dan has, I should say.
Enter a public defender.
That must be one of the fun
parts is how it's different.
-Yeah, it's very different.
It takes him a while to realize
that's what he's supposed
to be doing
because a few times the judge
has to remind him,
as he's scolding the defendant
and telling the judge
what a piece of crap
this guy is, come on.
She goes, "You know, you're
supposed to be defending him."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh. Well, no.
You didn't let me finish.
This young man is such
a pillar of society.
How could you possibly think
he did anything wrong?"
So, it was an interesting
dilemma.
And also, the idea that this
woman is the daughter of
Harry Stone, you know, made --
and that's what really melts
Dan Fielding to
some degree of humanity
to want to go and help her.
-It is a lot of similarities.
The set certainly brings me
back.
The theme song is a little
different and was tweaked by --
from within your family.
-Yes, my youngest son was born
during the heyday of
"Night Court" in 1987.
And Benjamin is an excellent
musician,
graduate of the Berklee College
of Music.
And my middle son is also
an artist and musician.
My daughter --
very artistic family.
But Ben called me one day
and said "Listen.
Listen to what I did.
I just did it."
He did it from memory and just
recorded it himself.
And so I thought, "That's a nice
new take on that."
So I showed it to Melissa
and Dan Rubin
with no intention of going,
"Hey, hey. Nepo, nepo, nepo."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you should never say
"nepo" out loud.
That's one of the things
we heard.
[ Laughter ]
-There you are. Yeah.
And they went, "Oh, my God.
This is fantastic.
It's perfect." And so he wound
up being the composer.
And he does all the interstitial
music within the --
So he is the composer of
the new "Night Court."
-That's really nice.
I want to ask,
having played a lawyer more than
once on television,
do you think you would make
a good lawyer?
-Um, I don't know.
I certainly wouldn't be a very
good public defender because I
would be unable to not take
money from people.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's very noble that you know
that about yourself.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, listen.
One accepts one's shortcomings
and tries to make
the best of them,
as we all do in life.
I don't know, and I don't know
why -- You know, I'm 6'5."
I have a deep voice.
Perhaps that seems somewhat
judicial or something,
you know.
And I played lawyers before
"Night Court."
You know, my very early career,
I was a lawyer on "Dallas"
of all things, a series that was
around in the late '70s.
So it wasn't just "Night Court"
that started that.
But certainly, there was
a cavalcade of them
after "Night Court" came along.
Serious and comedic as well.
-You were in a show
that I feel -- I remember
feeling very special
at the time.
It was critically adored.
It never quite became the sort
of ratings monster
that "Night Court" was, which
was "The John Larroquette Show."
Was that a show you look back on
and reflect on fondly
for how different it was?
-Yes, definitely fondly.
The only thing I don't like,
I hated the title.
I liked the show.
-Yeah.
Now, I should note
"The John Larroquette Show,"
not your idea.
-Not my idea at all.
I begged Warren Littlefield,
who was president of the network
at the time,
not to name it that
because -- and it was completely
ego because I knew eventually
one day I was going to look at
the Nielsen ratings
and it was gonna go, "number 76,
'The John Larroquette Show.'"
[ Laughter ]
But because of "Night Court,"
because of the first season,
we were pitted against
"Roseanne"
when she was in her heyday.
-Yeah.
-They thought at least that will
bring some people into the tent.
And I lost that battle.
But I think the idea of the
show, Don Reo's script that
I found, the first season of
that show I thought was --
I don't say this modestly --
some of the best sitcom
television ever made.
And the show changed because
wanting to try and get numbers,
wanting to try and get a larger
audience in.
It sort of changed,
and it was still funny.
Mitch Hurwitz came along
a couple years later,
ran it before he did
"Arrested Development,"
great comedy writer.
But it just sort of
lost its soul
a little bit and lost its way.
But, you know,
almost four years.
You can't really call it a flop
being on the air
for almost 100 episodes.
-No.
And again, as we talk about the
way the landscape has changed,
100 episodes now feels
like a million.
So it's really cool to be able
to do that much
storytelling with one show.
-I also do think that had we
done that show 10 years in the
future, when there was
a little more freedom in
the cable world of being able
to deal with certain subjects
that that show
would have had longer legs.
-I'm sure you still get
recognized from that.
Obviously, you get recognized
from "Night Court."
Is there any work you did way
back before those that you still
get recognized for that is
surprising to you?
-Yeah, "The Texas Chain Saw
Massacre."
-So, now you are -- What did you
do in "The Texas Chain Saw
Massacre"?
-The opening narration,
that's it.
-You were the opening narration?
How did that come to be?
-In the mid '60s somewhere --
I forget --
like Robin said, "if you
remember the '60s,
you weren't there."
[ Laughter ]
Living in a little town in
Colorado, being a bartender,
a fellow came in, we started
talking, a fellow named
Tobe Hooper and he said,
"Hey, I'm going to be
a movie director."
I went, "Yeah, sure.
Have another Coors."
[ Laughter ]
And he eventually went to L.A.
I eventually went to L.A.
Somehow, he found out I was
in L.A.
He called and said, "I made
this movie for nothing,
but it's a little horror film.
I need a favor."
And so I did this opening
narration of it.
I've never seen the film.
[ Laughter ]
Nor have I seen any of
the subsequent films
of "Texas Chain Saw Massacre."
-You're, like, waiting to do,
like, one big binge?
-Yes. Yes, right.
[ Laughter ]
And I actually did the
subsequent ones as well
and actually got money for them
as the years went on.
I think I've done three of them.
But still have never seen them,
not without Tobe.
Other people have done them.
But it's amazing to me that it
has stuck,
that it -- that --
Horror is not really my genre.
So I haven't been to
the midnight shows
of it or anything, but a lot of
people love that movie
and remember the fact that --
And I don't even think I got
a credit on it.
I don't think my name is
anywhere on it.
But people seem to have known
that I was the narrator.
-Well, that is a very cool first
way to break into the business.
And it is so nice you've stayed
in the business.
And it's so great
to have you here.
Thank you so much.
John Larroquette.
"Night Court" premieres with
back-to-back episodes
on January 17th and then will
air Tuesday nights
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.
We'll be right back with
more "Late Night."